all right so once again welcome everyone
to our new prisons again I'm so excited
to have everyone here and there's a
brief intro just wanna let you guys feel
like what we're about
so I not seen some familiar faces who is
here for the first time first time words
which is great because I mean we have
regulars and so our rocky UT we are
cookies science outreach at Rockefeller
University we work at the intersection
of basic science research and the stem
to collaborate with our community of
Sciences around fly University
professionals and stem to work with the
k-12 community in New York City so we're
really trying hard to provide access and
just share how amazing Sciences in
general because I think it's super cool
I think that he should think it's
difficult and so today we're having our
rocky do presents we have our our
community presents every third Friday of
the month today we have a civil engineer
from New York City next month April 20
and we actually have I think she's a
psychiatrist dr. Katie Davis and just
pulled my phone so I can tell you what
she's gonna do so she's actually going
to talk about the connection between
learning and disorders and anxiety and
how to Hutchinson discuss basic
strategies that's going to reduce school
related anxiety and improve your
studying
so if you have a difficult time studying
and you have anxiety yeah yeah I didn't
do I still live right there even
remotely interested in that please check
us out on next rock TV presents that
money of course one yet you have some
turkey demons coming in and so today we
have our New York City civil engineer
and just a little bit about her and then
I'll have her just introduce herself
a little more so she's Madelyn Scully
I'll sit on this many so she joined the
New York City Department of design and
construction early in 2016 she studied
civil engineering at the University of
wisconsin-madison and graduated in 2015
not only is she civil engineer but she
does enjoy doing other things such as
playing softball she runs that she's
pretty athletic she could probably
outrun me good enough and she also plays
an instrument so she II was in a
marching band in school and she plays
the trumpet and she enjoy music of all
sorts so today she'll talk about her
experience in NYC DC and how they work
on the infrastructure projects
throughout all five Ward's of New York
City so if anyone here basically new
yorkers and you've been wandering around
in the world to get everything to work
together so streamline you came to the
right place alright so join me as I
introduce Madeline
[Applause]
New York City Department of designing
construction construction projects
throughout will say that happy but also
but also all of the other boroughs in
the city so a little bit of my
background
I'm originally from Minnesota from right
outside of Minneapolis I went to college
of the University of wisconsin-madison
I graduated in 2015 I moved to New
York's shortly after in early 2016 for
the year in for a few years but I think
I've learned a lot in that amount of
time so my topic today is why New York
City works
Alesi and civil engineering so I'm gonna
be looking at all of the funds the
infrastructure that allows the city to
function on a day to day basis and
allows eight and a half million people
to exist and live work and recreation
innovative uses read their many groups
it wasn't here before so I'm gonna kind
of go into the history behind what
engineer
and the history of that so civil
engineering is the oldest engineering
discipline it's been around since the
person and beings walk the earth they
first one of their stable structure
maybe pushed a log over a river kind of
any man-made object that allows the
students with physical and built
environment civil engineering is a
discipline that deals with the design
starting and maintenance of the
physically a naturally built environment
and by built environment I mean all of
this so pretty much you're building zero
if your sidewalks curbs bridges all your
underground utilities and path through
the parks that we have the subway
station so you basically call me art
city like built environment I'm gonna go
through some of the different types of
civil engineering right now so there's
different subtypes these are just some
of them but we've got a structural
engineering which deals with buildings
bridges tunnels anything where you're
looking at how am I gonna support the
weight in this structure to make sure
that it doesn't fall down then you've
got transportation engineering so they
couldn't deal with the flow of vehicles
and people so that's like the signal
controls and they like the subway system
where you have the traffic signal
finding in the city to allow the traffic
to flow well that's all transportation
we have engineering construction and
management which is kind of what I do
this is taking the designs that people
make and practically implementing that
outside so I work directly with
construction workers
I don't do the construction work I just
oversee what they're doing so that's
kind of my management
then you've got geotechnical engineering
which is like your foundations
so what toil do we have underneath what
we're building it's important because
like you know you can have something
that the soil isn't good or it too much
water infiltration and you're putting a
building on top of it and it sinks into
the ground kind of like the Leaning
Tower of Pisa what happened with that
so geotechnical with all the materials
below that provide a good solid
foundation for your buildings or the
different structures that you're putting
up and then you've got Water Resources
which is where's our water coming phones
where is the water that we're getting to
cook or clean ourselves or different
things like that and then you want to be
putting out back into the file in the
waste water how we're treating that and
how that's going to be my recommendation
so these are all the some different
types of sub types of civil engineering
but these are all involved in
infrastructure work within the city so
if you know like when you're sick you'll
go to a doctor to get a diagnosis and a
cure I would consider the civil
engineers to be the doctors of the
infrastructure so there's any issue with
the building or a bridge something's not
functioning point right we go and we
diagnose with the extremis and then we
will provide a cure for that so I'm
gonna go into kind of the history of how
the city was formed so the first
settlers the Dutch settlers came to the
island of Manhattan in nine they choose
this location so typically for its
proximity to the East River and then
they'll say the Hudson River because
that went all the way north pink romaine
connected to valuable trading assets and
it could also be this as a military
outpost to protect the mainland
preventing invaders
so the Camden's kind of marque you Rocky
Hill eagle and the original went up and
again word was silent of many Hills
so obviously that changed a little bit
from what it was to what it is today
just in just over 400 years so kind of
looking at how it went from this to this
and all this isn't separate place to
change that one of the largest changes
the most drastic where actually these
family boarders of lower Manhattan so
this is the first known map that we have
at the city we have done this fortified
wall which is wall treatment and after
that
so that's Wall Street and then this is
like a military alcove you'd actually
for a trading post and then anything
you're the vistas pretty much unoccupied
land in the 1600
so once the population is very growing
you had people they initially just went
north on the island but then they wanted
to expand a little bit outward so they
build what was called
reclaimed land so all of this this is
the courage I guess a 1980 but it pretty
much looks like that now so they expand
it out by a thousand feet on either side
for clean land is basically where you
put a bunch of it's pretty much trash
it's like landfill into the water and
then you put dirt on top of that and
then you
so that was what this was sometimes they
would actually sink entire ships and use
that as a foundation for buildings
himself you find that I'm sure we could
find more than with a phone one when
they were rebuilding the World Trade
Center in 2010 they dug down far enough
so they found the fall of this ship and
they traced it back to 1773 apparently
was made out of Philadelphia so that was
like one of the most recent finds anyway
so they used to do that and a lot of the
land in lower Manhattan
now really Upper Manhattan but down here
is reclaimed like Ellis Island Rikers
Island pretty much all of FDR drive
we're pretty close to that right now in
Battery Park City that they actually
built from all of the dirt that they
they ex giving it out from the World
Trade Center site so they just excavated
it and like moved it down and then built
the Battery Park City so one of the less
aggressive changes oh I thought this was
pretty interesting so like the outline
of an Hatton Island as it was in 1609 is
its redline and then when hurricane
sandy came through this is the storm
surge area so you can kind of see how it
like though is pretty much up and tell
that original outline of the island
event happened so I'm thinking if we
hadn't reclaimed all of this land would
it have flooded as bad as it did me
Carolee know but it's interesting to
think about
there's uh loose men in the early 1900s
they wanted to infill the East River and
I'm like I don't know how this would be
done takes a lot of dirt to fill any but
they were trying to like fill this in
and make a new East River through cities
in Brooklyn like I don't I don't want to
mess with the with the original land
because like if there's water flowing in
one direction it usually will come back
and try to want that area again as you
can see from the last slide so maybe
it's visit we didn't do that and also at
this point they were expanding a lot and
manufacturing jobs which means they need
a lot more land a nice thing we're
building up but then you're building out
but then once manufacturing start going
down the early nineteen hundred's they
actually started going upward because
people could just work in office
buildings and generate money through
that so they didn't need the extra land
that's that's kind of why they expect
this plant you know that we use a
million gallons of water a day in the
city of New York so this is the Central
Park Reservoir but um basically water is
essential to the to the functioning of
the city if you don't have water you
have no city because people can live
without electricity they can live
without the other luxuries that they
can't live without water so I'm kind of
going through all of the processes that
were put in place to allow us to have
stable clean reliant drinking water
right now
so the original water sourcing on the
island they were all finite surfaces
water like the water table below ground
they would use small streams on stuff
like that they have this thing called
the collect pond which is kind of in
like Chinatown and like the Five Points
area that's where this was
and so that's right a lot of people got
their water at that point obviously they
can't get it from the ocean because it's
saltwater here's another picture that I
found this is the collect on and this is
a little rocky hilly outcropping here
they provided the first two centuries of
water Manhattan but as people as one of
our people came to the island and they
started living and the human-animal
basically leaked into the water and it
became really polluted so over time and
had to find new sources for this one of
the catalyst for this was actually the
prevalence of fires and 1800's they
wanted to develop a waterworks system
which is kind of like a comprehensive
reliable clean drinking distribution
system so they have a lot of players
happening because the population grew
you had a lot more buildings like wooden
buildings close together and my brothers
didn't get the water to where they
needed it to be they would you know they
didn't have like a hydrant system or
anything like that I feel like we take
that for granted but they didn't have a
system underground providing them with
water so they'd have to like use bucket
lines like over here stuff like that so
to prevent any further large large fires
they wanted to set up this water work
system
so they actually set up a system of
wooden water mains interesting thing
about this is that well they may end up
using I think they had a law passed when
they had sourced the water from the
Bronx River but whoever was running this
lemon very good may they end up still
sourcing it from lower Manhattan from
the ground water table from the little
wells that they already have down there
they put a reservoir in heard a Tribeca
and they were using rekha horsepower to
later speeding power engine to pump this
up and then they had a system of wooden
water mains which are like logs and that
they bore through with an auger that
could have just removed the interior it
makes like a cylindrical hole in the log
and then they taper one end to the other
and they can fit them together so pump
the water into this system and then it
would just flow by gravity down a - to
the different parts of the city
obviously most of the people that had
like their own house connections were
very wealthy people at this time the
poor people at a keep lying on the
ground water levels and stuff like that
and there are some other flaws with this
- like the wooden water mains this is
one being removed from a trench you can
still find them once in a while and
lower Manhattan is I think this is a
South Street Seaport but what if they
were susceptible the tree-ring
infiltration soy trees would grow about
them and then the roots would go into
the logs or they would freeze in the
winter it just wasn't a reliable source
because they were still using the finite
water sources from like this area the
collect pond in different areas like
that so they had to find another source
they ended up here some logs on display
at the GDC
yeah my place of employment so we have a
few Lots here we need a lot of water
workers in the city is the cultic
service and that's kind of the work that
we do I think that the public would use
this an example is some that we found
recently the internet building this
aqueduct system and the mid-1800s called
the Croton Aqueduct where they dammed a
lake up here with Westchester County and
then they built a bunch of a series of
bridges or aqueducts and tunnels so I'd
offered up just like a large arched
bridge where they can allow water to
flow gravity slows down and then they
had some tunnels over here the high
bridge is actually one of the easiest
projects when we did the restoration of
that recently and blowed all the way
down into this receiving reservoir which
is actually where the Great Lawn is now
in Central Park then I went down to this
progeny distributing reservoir which
this is where I think the designer
doctor like ancient Egyptian
architecture kind of looks like that and
this is where the New York Public
Library is now and run apart so it's
kind of interesting and then it would
flow out from there but this drastically
change tell people to live help the
quality of people's lives at that time
today they were able to have consistent
clean water sources that bath house is
open to the public
disease was going down because things
weren't you know they didn't have they
didn't have to use the polluted water
anymore stuff like that that was it's
really beneficial to the city one of the
other downsides of this though is that
people weren't drunk as much water from
the water table below so it's turning
pricing again and then you had people's
basements and sellers starting to flood
they'd end up having to install a sewer
system to get the water out away from
those now I will talk about that in a
little bit but this is the first awkward
exit so they set up they rebuilt a newer
larger one and 1890 I believe and then
this is the current New York City water
supplies
so this is the approved watersheds
that's not what I was talking about
before
and then they'd expand it all the way up
here to the Catskill Delaware watershed
so the New York City water system is
considered kind of the gold standard of
urban water supply systems in the world
so we have some of the best water and
and the largest system ever made here's
the Highbridge restoration but you see
that was anyway so the water comes from
they put in a few more upper decks over
here it comes all the way down again
this is all gravity flow then it goes to
its familiar watersheds here because the
water is unfiltered coming into this and
to make sure they're getting all the
contaminants out they used to so they
found this technology in the late
nineties called
well where you can basically treat
different toxins with UV light into the
water so like Cryptosporidium was one of
them that they were trying to deal with
basically you treat it with UV light
that'll get rid of that so they can put
less for me into this water they
actually save them a lot of money doing
this versus building a giant wastewater
treatment plant so they put a lot of
money into this but it has saved a lot
over time after it goes to the 10
billion each plant gonna go down into
these water turtles we've got three of
them now the first year were built in
the early 1900s and the third one was
just open in 2013 it had been under
construction since the nineteen seven
that's a very long time and these are
built I mean they're huge tunnels as you
can see they're built really deep in the
ground
probably like 800 feet down and it's all
gravity flow so comes out of the cattle
you ain't planning goes into these
tunnels and the pressure of the water is
so large they have these shafts going up
to the surface that it'll just shoot up
these shafts and it'll go into this
trunk water main system which is like
they're probably three to five feet in
diameter larger pipes going trough the
city and then you go into a distribution
water main system that would be stuff
that we replace on a regular basis it's
like one point ductile iron pipes and
those are going down every single Street
in the city usually you'll have like two
lines on an Avenue and just one on like
a regular Street and then you've got
house connections going to each building
from there so I found this this for the
air just like this image well just
showing that the reservoir up here
dropping what the sea level these would
be like the the shoots going up into the
city and the water distribution system
today it's another little image so it's
kind of showing these are all the pipes
are all underground so you've got like a
hydrant connection here you've got your
house connection going in to give you
your shower water your bathroom water or
whatever you're cooking and cleaning
with fountain over here the fights they
used to use we've actually advanced our
technology enough to the point where
well they used to use like cast iron and
they use these like jointer led
service one can do stuff like that lab
you say it's toxic to people so we don't
want to use that and Catherine gets
really brittle over time so they break a
lot so we've been putting in these other
pipes ductile iron pipes so hopefully
that'll last a lot longer
that's a lot of what PVC does though is
water distribution replacement I
mentioned the sewers before so this is
when people stop stop taking water from
the existing water tables and it started
rising and then flooding every one
basement so they set up the system of
sewers or the few different types I'm
sure you've seen this it's what we
consider a catch basin right these are
the sense of the road it's just a great
that water will flow into how this works
as a road is set up so that there's a
crown in the middle of it so you've got
a gown when he's sloped on either side
going to the curve
that's purposely done obviously because
you don't want water pooling in the
middle of your street so they do this
and then it'll go into wherever the
lowest point of the road is and it'll go
into this catch basin and it'll go into
an outlet pipe into a larger system and
then into like a wastewater treatment
plant so that's a storm all that waste
into a sanitary sewer pipe to a
treatment plant you can look at any of
the manholes and the ground I mean
really go out and look at like all of
the different you'll be able to tell
exactly where the water lines are
running where the sewer lines are
running would you go and look at the
covers of these things and some
anyways the systems here they originally
had all of that water running together
so they thought like storm suit your
rainwater and then your wastewater from
your house running through the second
pipe they figured out later that it was
actually more convenient and efficient
to separate them into separate lines but
the city failed them so long ago that we
just replaced was already in the ground
because there's too much stuff running
I'll show you a picture later and look
dieted it's so crowded whatever you try
to do into the ground so we just
replaced what's existing so they're
combined right now so the green is all
combined sewers orange or separated
sections and then the grey was no other
directory News Service trainer - stuff
like that in the rest of the country
because it was built a lot later like
right from there all separated but they
had come up with that technology at that
point so then the sewer water recedes to
the various sewer sheds and to the
corresponding wastewater treatment
plants so you kind of find where you
live and what what treatment plan is
treating your water I think the new time
Creek in Greenpoint actually services
the most in this area but they don't
take some water in it'll go through a
series of filters and we'll break down
the waste and anything and then they'll
get the clean water out again and be
able to release that into the oceans
into the streams stuff like that it's
kind of other the sewer system works
waste reduction and sanitation so we
know about this because if you go out in
the summer it's so awful right all the
garbage it's on the curb the original
system I think it was it was much worse
from what I hear in the past some people
would like throws garbage out their
windows onto the street they dumped it
at the harbors the point that I actually
found that they had this system of trash
being pigs like a bunch of pigs that
would work whatever brought around
they didn't have as many plastics and
something you know that we do now so
they would heat all of that and then
eventually they decided it was
unsanitary and they got the picked out
the city because they hired a bunch of
people they called the white wings a
relevant white because they wanted to
emphasize cleanliness and sanitation and
so they were kind of the street sweepers
you know they were getting all the
travell the trash out of the streets
that was the first comprehensive
sanitation system that they had in this
ending life so liquor in system you know
we're still kind of doing that with just
picking up trash off the curb but the
issue is we don't have anywhere to put
and use this because you can't you know
there's no alleyways built into the city
I always think about like Oh Chicago if
they have the great fire Chicago I feel
like they got a second chance to refuse
like they're saying it's not a good
thing but but they got to they were able
to put in the you know the alleyway is
to develop a better trap system so New
York never got that chance I think
whoever figures out how to deal with
this will be a very rich person but the
Roosevelt Island treasure system which
was built a lot more recently is
actually kind of out trash conveyor belt
so in all the buildings people can put
their trash into this chute and then
it'll go down and onto this this
conveyor belt and you whisked out
underneath the island that was kinda
cool
transportation growth so how the city
grew in terms of the options for
transportation that they had it early on
obviously it was just like walking or
riding animals or being pulled in a cart
by an animal so the commissioners plan
of 1811 they had this idea for this huge
grid which here is pretty much known for
DNA but they were having issues with
people trying to claim land plots people
were fighting over you know what the
price is what
besides events going to be they didn't
have any way to regulate how people were
buying lots of planner and to make sure
that the streets were running in
straight lines and stuff like that so
they decided to set up this whole system
of avenues streets all the way at the
island which is come a bold idea because
they only had a hundred thousand people
living there at the time such enter the
bait that you're gonna have you're gonna
undergo construction and have who knows
how many people live in here that will
fill up the rest of this island in the
future how the city has grown from that
point on so I set up this grid and
that's really while they also
acknowledge like this is Broadway which
this was the original Indian Trail going
all the way up the island of Manhattan
so that's why it's diagonal running
through the middle of the of the city
and then of course you know Central Park
is in here so there were some different
changes that had to be made eventually
that they added it but this was the ton
of the original design the I think they
actually thought about doing like you
know in Washington DC that has those
Chinese circles I thought about doing
that at one point someone was very
adamant so that wasn't the way to do
focus and even you have the design the
curved buildings on you at the designs
round circles it's a lot easier to build
just a rectangular building every in
every way it was just more effective to
to set up the city like this so they
were able to make you know put all of
the subways along the street lines they
could run all of the utilities along
those same lines and then into each
building as if it's built up and on each
block of the city
early transportation options then were
they have these elevated these elevated
railways hell else they had horse-drawn
carriages they had trolley cars a lot of
the time we were taking myself behind
like trolley tracks in the ground so
these were the original of these some of
the options they had early on and they
as the population grew more and more
they needed a larger system that could
that could handle the volume of people
that wanted to travel on it and so they
decided to build a subway and they also
didn't have anywhere to go other than
below ground because they already had
above-ground systems and stuff on the
streets so decided to build on the
ground they use the cutting cover method
which is basically where you dig a hole
in the street like a trench and you
solidify the sides and then you put like
a support above so that people can drive
or whatever you know walk on top of this
that will support that it's kind of what
that looks like and then you can work
below there so it also can finds them to
building in the street grid itself
because you can't do the cover method
when you have a building there I mean
they they could have done like a deep
boring method but they didn't have the
technology at that point that's how they
built the second Avenue subway where
they said this giant boring machine and
it was really really deep in the ground
but at that point it's it's like you
don't have any other room there's
utilities there's other fittings over
there so that's why they did it that way
for the second Avenue but when they were
first you mean it
they didn't have the technology
they also built the underwater tunnels
so they would dig down until they got to
the like the muddy silty material just
below the river and then they would kind
of get into that and then they would lay
all the bricks around it to support that
and then to keep the water out they they
pump in pressure on his air what they
found out though this is people would
come down something called the bends
which is like divers sickness because
when you have like this pressurized air
inside of you and then you go up to the
surface too quickly you have all these
air bubbles in you it's like it creates
an imbalance and people get really sick
from it they didn't know this at the
time so this is how they were building
everything so they would also go and
gate all the way down to the bedrock way
below the bottom of the river and then
they would like a gate and try to serve
each each other in the middle which is
kind of animal because how do you know
you're gonna actually you have to be
very very accurate with this so I think
that's kind of an interesting and people
have made mistakes at this before like
they've missed you know that's difficult
to correct so that they were able to do
that at that point it's it's kind of a
big deal I think they also had some
decorative Subway's this is a City Hall
subway which I guess you can I don't
know I haven't been there you know which
I mean if you're not going to go there
I guess you have to ride to the end of
one of the subway but they put a lot of
hard work into this as well another
thing you can look at is I'm sure you
can see names like little round glass
pieces are lower than happy right so
these are actually little lights for
people to work under so they have so
underneath all of those you've got
building bolts and people used to work
down there I don't know if they still do
I'm thinking not but that's how some of
this was set up and then like this I was
working at a store place these are if
you look at the material that you have
you can see like credits laughs and
stuff like that these are all building
vaults or subway bolts stuff like that
we weren't allowed to make that up
because if we if we pull that off that's
literally the the root of this
underground vault area so we have to
build around that storage area but
anyways sometimes they would build the
station so high up that this at the top
of it was the sidewalk and I makes a
difficult battle replace so
and you got like your bridges of course
which really revolutionized how people
were able to it revolutionize like the
social culture in the city too because
if you think about it people are living
in Brooklyn it's hard to get over to
Manhattan and a wreath like in a quick
way so building a bridge a lot of people
to live in an outer borough and then
travel over to work in Manhattan and
then come back so that was kind of
interesting how this really connected
all the borough's and created the city
system as it is today they built this
the like the foundation parts of it with
these things called caissons which are
basically like if you take a box you can
take hollow and you took out the bottom
part of it you force it into the ground
and you create a shaft in there where
you can pump the water out below it and
then dig out and people are allowed to
work down there that's without it
and they would also pump in pressure
right there into this so people would
get the bends from building this so
that's the Brooklyn Bridge they built
mostly about this way then you've got
your power source and then your
utilities so we've got just kinda go fit
as quickly you've got like your steam
power which is an old you know you just
heat up water and the steam will rise
and you need upper heating and cooling
system and they break the way through
humanity
it's used for disinfectants you've ever
seen these scheme towers here that just
if you have excess scheming allows it to
release in a safe way and you've got gas
use for heating cooking heating
electricity generation and get
electricity he likes chargers for
devices and small appliances and then
your telephone and Internet of course
steam and gas run through large pipes
underground electricity and telephone
when that was first they used to put up
these huge old and you can imagine what
the city would look like if they had
left this gear like I'm sure I would
have just gotten worse we're lucky that
they decided to put them all below
ground at a certain point in a lot of
the other girls in our home below ground
but they had decided how to do that
so now you get this basically you take
up the road and it all looks like
spaghetti you know like a nerd cross you
never know what you're gonna find when
you dig down because like a lot of the
records have been lost over the over the
years so you never quite know what
you'll find this is one of my pictures
from one of the sites we were working on
and then it's quickly unlike the
evolution of skyscrapers in the city so
the skyscraper didn't really come around
until the elevator was invited to be
think about it they're the richest
tenant of a building like no one wants
to walk up ten flights of stairs to get
to an office right so the richest
tenants would always want the ground
floor suite because people would go
there they wouldn't go up all these
steps once the elevator was invented
though everyone wanted the penthouse
suite the view that everything you were
able to get up and down pretty easily so
that really changed the skyline of
Manhattan I'm gonna go into kind of what
I do on a daily basis now so I do
infrastructure construction this is one
pictures from our site I think we're
late water me what I mean they'll ask an
inspector I don't wear this on regular
basis so so what I do on a regular basis
is kind of everything roadway and below
so we do sidewalks curbs pedestrian
ramps we do roadway restorations we
replace water main high sewer pipe we
work around utilities like I mentioned
before like stevia and electricity all
those lines that are intercrossing there
we deal with that everyone will ask me
you know can you fix the subway and I
say look you know figure out you work
next to it you must be able to kind of
in a jogging way and I'm like no they're
very protective over their stations they
don't let you touch it at all if you
scratch one of them they're like replace
it you know so we're really careful
around that well we do all of this stuff
will do Plaza features I worked at Astor
Place oh my I want you I don't get that
over here but I came on coming at the
end of it but we put the cube back and
therefore that's we get to work with
public art we do like specialty like
sidewalk work in historic areas it's
tinted like a darker color and then you
might have like an exposed aggregate
with it but you did say like concrete
can be fancy but it can't so we've got
now we did plant we work with Landscape
Architects to create like bench systems
these are granite benches or steps we've
got planting areas we do all these
different features so it's kind of
interesting is you're really going to
create the landscape and what people
will be using
Jase's you get to work with all types of
people so we work this is us in front of
the queue we work the elucidate
department the Department of
Environmental Protection the d-o-t
Department of Transportation the parts
department we worked with the
construction workers we work with its
architects we work with Landscape
Architects I've got to work with
archaeologists because if we're digging
down in the in the short areas we might
find something that's against people
with row their trash into the ground so
you never know what you're going to find
down there we work with community boards
we work with the mayor's office all the
people that's pretty interesting this is
what stuff we found
so this is an old pipe like that you can
pick these I think so this hasn't been
touched in probably 150 years I said was
in there but we took it out this is all
like iron deposits so that's what we're
taking out at the ground so everyone
gets mad that we're replacing their
water man I said you know this is what
you were drinking out of before so we're
putting a new one in so this old shovel
or 1850s
since that this wouldn't handle sounds
kind of cool pretty impact and I
actually know that the person I was
running this project because nearly at
least one but they found a little
variable near Washington thrown apart
because it used to be like a potter's
field
spen of these bodies in it and they had
to call the archaeologists over and stop
the project for a while that's kind of a
coming so early commissioner said once
as we build the future of New York we
rediscover the past so I like that
statement so coming as they're digging
up we really get to understand how how
things were done in the past and how
that relates what we're doing today and
I'm going to show this video here in a
second
[Music]
different easy
[Music]
[Music]
clean water continues to be delivered to
all I'm building for the states in the
Armed Forces
I'm building for libraries and building
for literacy this is a pathetic and
actually separate apartment
before we were to improve public health
through the designer abilities I'm
building for a better urban environment
I'm building to preserve educate and
inspire one thing one thing
all the employees professional and
dedicated to zero under the permit these
things are beautiful
I'm living equality and whatever we get
to pride in technologies which will be
proved a life and quality of our
projects and building a better city to
preserve our resources with an
extermination and building that meets
the needs of the occupant equitable cost
to the taxpayers for a system of
preventative maintenance funding for the
future of all New Yorkers I'm doing to
ensure communities of no wrong form
I know me better prosperity of small
businesses in the city I'm building for
equality and I'm building for inclusion
and building for a city that makes
people motor signals Thursday I'm
looking for the greatest city in the
world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so thanks everybody for coming now
is the time for you guys to ask whatever
question that is you know relevant to
your lives regarding the talk like you
just heard as with a for anybody who's
new any question anybody who asks asks a
question also or sees some piece of swag
so today we have hats so let's start we
had someone over here and we're gonna
ask you to ask your question fully wait
for the microphone before you ask your
question and for anybody who's not used
to using a microphone it's like you
almost have to like eat the microphone
okay just so we can make sure that we
hear your question correctly okay so
let's start off over here sorry
so what made you want to be yeah so I
looked at meteorology at one point it's
very different to come but I was looking
into engineering at a certain point
because I like math and science and
going to a lot of opportunities and I
was thrown deciding between the
different types and I was looking at
like mechanical or civil and I just
liked the idea of I don't want to deal
with all the moving parts alizarin but I
like video filming is very visual it's
very relatable to people you know we
play the work at all time so it was
something that I can see them tangible
and I like the idea of designing for
that so I don't know you can have a big
impact on your environment with the work
with everyone in this I'm creating stuff
that's going to be here for like
hundreds of years now so I'd like to be
a part of that so I think
simple engineering about ciggy civil
engineering in particular what's the big
part of your job I like that I can be
outside a lot I kind of kind of happen
at office half outside so I can like go
to the site and be out there I just go
to do science like everything like we
have a multi-site project right now I'm
off in like in wood at one point and
then I throw all them at Brooklyn like
in the same day and I don't know like
it's the travel and the experience I
guess there's been less underground
stuff is yet further uptown since it's
newer
I would say yes in a way a little bit
less than I mean I don't even know about
that it's better to something like in
wood and there's a whole lot of stuff
still bad I guess there's less older
things like there might be less
abandoned utilities it's probably all
active at this point so sometimes in the
oh you know down there we'll find like
like old conduits that are we don't know
if they're they're active or not so I
think there's less of that but there's
still plenty of utilities the population
stays you know it's pretty crowded
everywhere on the other
so yeah let's hold the artifacts I would
say though
you want to feel just one here in the
center
my question is where do you see civil
engineering going in the next 10 years
or with like real technological
advancements future technological
advancements I mean I think it's all
going to become the green energy
movement so it's integrating that
technology versus buildings you know
they're using things that like curtain
walls and different other technology
where you're you're you're reducing
heating and cooling costs and stuff like
that in terms of ladies I don't really
know if you can reinvent the wheel on
come on for you because it's been there
forever
you know there's pretty much no you've
done everything you can with that so I
think it would be finding ways to figure
out how to use materials and new ways
maybe smart rooms maybe you know stuff
where you're using different plastics
and things that are a little more
durable than just like asphalt and stuff
like that it's kinda where I see it
going in terms of infrastructure yeah we
have a couple of hands on over here
so we have so many cities in the United
States what made you choose their City
yeah you grew up not if you're not from
here it's you know we see it in the
media and everything if you're from like
the Midwest or something it's it's in
everything so I think that's it just the
largest city you can go to in terms of
doing city infrastructure work so I kind
of wanted I like the city in general
like all the other people and the hustle
and bustle and all of that but I also
like the chance to work in a very
challenging environment because if
you're working in like a soda we don't
have all these utilities in the growth
so it's not going to be it'll be easier
but it I like the challenge of working
in New York and the history of you know
being able to dig and find all its old
stuff because it's got like the oldest
infrastructure in the u.s. so I think
that was the reason why I chose here was
the opportunity for her experience yeah
one question up here so you were
returning Chicago Fire and Sandy do you
think there is any catastrophe which can
destroy the city or bit do a big damage
I mean I guess another like I don't
think the fires would do it now I think
we have a comprehensive system to fight
that but maybe another really bad
hurricane you know we're not gonna get
an earthquake's everybody never gonna
get tornados or anything so maybe
another worse hurricane that would cause
more damage but I don't know what I was
gonna come there trying to set up
systems right now like with the South
Street Seaport in that area to like make
it a Hillier so you have like more
barriers before you get into the city
itself so they'll stop the flow of like
the storm surge so they're implementing
stuff hopefully protect this but I don't
think anything will necessarily destroy
it like a natural disaster
we're gonna go over here
[Music]
what are some misconceptions about your
job
[Music]
you know my own color Sherman asked me
where I told her I got I have a city car
and she thought that you know and then I
mentioned it was obvious and she thought
I was gonna I was like a big pickup
truck or something
so there's misconceptions about like you
know you're doing city engineering
versus other types and I think also the
amount of venjix engineering that I am
doing personally is I'm not in the
design side of it so the people might
think that I designed like the Romans or
whatever but there are other people that
design this and I I get it like three
years later and then we're just looking
for the separation there so I'm doing
less of the actual you know the civil
engineering design I could get into that
eventually if I wanted to because I kind
of like being out in the world and
implementing it in that way so I think
those are the assumptions
[Music]
so I'm visit right now and good thinking
about where they're in atomic energy
sources and you know we almost didn't
know that like biofuels are involved in
or what resource and while doing a
search on something yeah like roast at
Boyd like like me on solar panels and
like wood or like rows where the cars
drive gonna do is take energy from the
car and we eventually be used to power
the whole city do you think that's like
a realistic goal that New York City can
achieve you know the weather and how do
you rather prove that you know sometimes
they try to implement stuff and it
doesn't quite go the way you think it
will my TV's gonna take a long time when
they get to that basically yeah all
right ok so many questions ok
okay so remember how you talked about
they were building trains underground
like how they're still trains that are
outside today it's like how it has over
yeah some of the trains like the Bronx
Queens and Brooklyn so go outside it
could be like the material they were but
maybe that that brought there it was
like really high they didn't want to
tunnel through that I'm not sure I'm
sure maybe they could it's probably a
money issue they you know the MTA is
enough money to like fix the issues I
think you have why would they put one
underground you know when they don't
necessarily have to so I think that's
currently working on the trains because
do signal problems
oh I need to get the school
well cool yes thank you
we did a water test at our school and I
know you mentioned an UV treatment of
the water we found like really low
chlorine levels according to our at-home
testing kits I mean they were at home
tests but those near so you have lower
chlorine levels because we use the UV
treatment or should we still have the
same flow rate like minimum chlorine
levels I think it's actually I think
it's actually lower for sure that's
that's what I think that's why they
implemented out in the first place so I
don't know if there's other places that
have like more filtration because if we
have done like I'm what a waste water
treatment for maybe we could have got
some more layers a million for that
possible money than what they UV like us
so I think that we do have lower levels
I mean I find other parts of the country
and taste in the water and it's not
great so this is this is really good
about why did you choose New York City
and I kind of wanted to like forward
that and say like why didn't you want
like a challenge of bringing something
new into like a smaller location that's
not as modern as New York City you know
I think it's just learning well I don't
know what's in these stuff yet like I'm
still you know I've been working for
like several
I think I could eventually do that
that's one of the goals is to bring it
to newer areas but I have to come here
first to get the experience and then
maybe able to take that elsewhere and
you know we don't I mean we have a lot
of new technology but a lot of the stuff
is older so there are areas of the
country that you have newer technology
that we do just because they implemented
it more recently so I don't know we can
still think about new things in this
area all right couple over here - whoa
sorry
how long does it take to become a civil
engineer so I'm kind of still in the
process of that is you have to get to
officially call yourself an engineer you
have to get a professional engineers
license at least within the civil
engineering so I mean I graduated but I
moved like a month later and I've had a
job already when I came here and then
within like six months they made me run
an engineer which is fairly fast but I
just thought that I got the opportunity
but you have to work for four years
before you get your Professional
Engineers license and then that really
opens doors and you can even design
stuff you can sign your name to it and
stuff like that so it was it wasn't that
long to get this job I would say but in
terms of climate on an actual engineer
insanity like in a year maybe so yeah
just to follow up on that what was your
major in college
civil engineering so it was all right
sorry hi how physically I guess I just I
don't know the piping systems weight
pickups okay so there is your like your
standard pipe and one end is kind of
like a balance sheet and one is called
the spigot but it's straight and then
you have like this little they put in
like a rubber like I don't even call it
a seal and then they do they've got
these little metal things in it they
call the teeth so it's kind of like what
do you have a Chinese like finger thing
you know where when you pull it apart it
just increases in strength so it has
this seal system to you push it in and
then you can't pull it apart because the
things within the seal will dig into the
metal so that's how so they just push
one into the other
it's really not like that much more
complicated than that push one of the
other and then keep doing that so that
would when there's stress is trying to
pull it apart it just it strut it
tightens up basic wood like the Chinese
everything
kind of isn't using 30 like downsides to
being sublime here like which elites the
favorite thing about being cookies it
can be a little intense especially if
you're working construction like the the
culture of that is very like rough I
would say so maybe the fighting with the
head and contractors are always trying
to fight you for more money and if they
kind of watch them so they don't try to
you know cut orders with stuff and like
not give you the best product not all of
them do that but a lot of them do so
they're trying to make money out of this
it's like a business thing I think
trying to like always being on edge
trying to make sure that and then people
fighting about it we trying to you know
make sure that the best quality work is
still done despite that so that's
probably that stuff yeah
anywhere questions of what were some of
the motivators that help you become an
engineer I think in at home my dad is
kind of an engineering type so they
promoted what I was interested in in
science and in math and something that I
really promoted like oh I think that was
when I first heard about it and then he
was just the farther I got into it
school the more interesting I found it
like like I mean I think concrete look
very interesting we have a question over
here
okay I'm gonna don't love students so
yeah but speaking of concrete this we
could South by Southwest they introduced
the idea of 3d printing a home they took
six hundred dollars worth of materials
and they 3d printed this new kind of
concrete to use yeah it's super
interesting do you see applications for
3d printing for civil structures oh yeah
we have our I mean are you doing
anything now we are telling more I mean
I'm not personally I also
the mentorship for my school students
through GDC for pinnacle days
architecture construction engineering
and we're looking into an inflexible
type but we don't study a modular homes
so this technology is all there it's
just I don't it's not implemented on a
large scale level yeah so what you can I
see that definitely becoming something
that I know people that are looking into
3d print like modular homes and in a
real sense right now
so this is something that I think will
definitely be because you produce like
labor costs and the time it takes you
know you can produce stuff off-site and
bring it over there yeah I definitely
think this is something right so my
question for you is being a woman in the
engineering field could you give some
advice for the young ladies in the
audience about her experiences and maybe
some tips on like how you got to her
like what success I'd say like I don't
know I I don't think of myself as like a
woman engineer I think of myself like an
engineer
yeah
okay so it sounds like I'm different or
doing anything differently than what it
means the guys are doing actually like
all the notes that I work with and then
there are other women that I work with
too but I think it's just like you know
you can deal with the older the older
guys that only worked in a certain way
and stuff like that you just have to
hold your own with that and not fight
back against it and not get it really
it's easy to get really angry about it
but I really try to hold my emotions and
stuff like that
on a day to day basis and I think of
anything there's more opportunities for
women because they're really trying to
promote other you know diversity things
all that so if anything I've only been
helped by that I don't think I've been
held back at all so I think if you have
the motivation to do it and you can
handle you know what you're doing
obviously if you want to go into it and
studied and everything you're fully
capable to do anything that you know is
out of the box I guess
okay there's one more over here speaking
from experience studying simple is hard
if you're really challenged you did you
ever go to a point in time in school
that you mean like had to sit and like
reevaluate indecision of studying so I
think everyone pushes women into stem
and our students into stem and they
never really talked about just struggle
behind it but it's not like it's not a
reality that students go through so can
you like talk about it and what you did
to get through it yeah yeah there was
like I mean maybe many moments but like
especially later at college when it's
when you're really tired at studying all
the time and you're just ready to be
done you're kind of burnt out and it's
getting really difficult that I was I
was like oh I'm going to do this I don't
know and I think you would but I mean
you can I guess at that point I was like
almost done with my degree so I wasn't
going to not get it but once I got
through the difficult portion of that
but I got my degree and then I got out
here and I was like oh this is what I
wanted to do so I think you have to come
and get through like I mean sometimes
it's it's overwhelmingly difficult if
it's making your life like you you have
no interest in whatsoever
maybe you should love towards are
different but I think I understand that
I was still interested in it and I
didn't felt like I was pushed in to it
just because like I went into it because
I was interested in
so I think it's discerning kind of
whether you're you feel like you're
being pushed into this for different
reasons or if you went into it willingly
and you're interested in it and you're
just having a tough time with the
material because once you get colored
it's really probably the most difficult
part of all you don't think it's
rigorous and math and everything and
very difficult and then when you get out
into working world it's different
challenges I'd say not the same type of
intensity of math and science so I still
apply a lot of the concepts that I do to
my job now but not the same ones I guess
yeah
can I round it out with a question of my
own we orient so Rakhi to you we work a
lot on microbes and microbial
communities and things like that and I
know a lot of people are studying how
microbes are kind of creating their own
little niche environments in the built
environment and so I was just wondering
if you've ever come across or if you or
people in your field are considering
like microbial types of biofilms or
building materials of that nature to
integrate into the buildings as we sort
of start thinking about these smart
buildings
I heard about being implemented that
would be cool yeah you know because I
mean these microbes are everywhere
anyway so and you can manipulate them to
create energy and all these other people
are working on those concepts at least
right there's nothing commercially
available and so I I don't know I just
was wondering about the intersection of
this like robiola community I'm in the
environment I don't know I don't know or
like layer maybe like by we put we
played like Bible soils where we we try
to get all of the bad materials that
come on the street or they go in the
sewer system maybe something like that
when you're you know out in the
environment there itself
I don't yeah the being
yeah and just out of curiosity oh we do
have another question all right one more
question and then we'll visit the
neverkey hold on hi in your opinion have
you seen a decrease or increase in the
number of jobs in the field of civil
engineering because of the development
of Technology definitely an increase I
mean I guess the infrastructure is is
well I will never run out of work did
you basically because the infrastructure
is breaking down you know it's really
old so it's like we're gonna have to
keep it I don't know if it's techno I
guess it is technology but but we just
have to replace the old systems so that
they don't break by the time those get
old we'll have to replace it again so
you know I I think it's it's continuous
cycle like you'll never run out of work
for a simple engine and that's why you
didn't feel to go into if you're
interesting is you always be able to
find a job yeah great so let's give
Maddie around
[Applause]